hello folks
welcome to rational science the only
site on the internet that does physics
everybody else does particles or they
move concepts around
anyways we have an exciting day today
we're going to find out what a sphere is
and yeah i know flat lenders need to
listen to this
lecture okay i'm going to start with a
little bit of news
that i heard the other day back today
and uh i related to extinction
okay which is subject uh that we also
touch
on this site okay and it's about this
fellow
see if i can get him up here his name is
ed
snowden okay and
this gentleman now uh sold at what is
known as a
non-fungible token nft
for five million dollars
so what is an unfungible uh token
is a unit of data stored on a blockchain
that certifies
digital asset to be unique
and therefore not interchangeable nfts
can be used to represent items such as
photos videos
audio and other types of digital files
while copies of these digital items are
available for anyone to obtain
nfts are tracked on blockchains to
provide the
owner with a proof of ownership that is
separate from copyright
in 2021 there has been increased
interest in using
nfts blockchains like ethereum
flow tazos have their own standards when
it comes to supporting nfts
but each works to ensure that the
digital item represented as
authentically
one-of-a-kind nfts are now being used to
commodify
digital assets in art music etc and
popular entertainment
the nft market value tripled in 2020
reaching more than
250 million dollars the rise of mft
transaction has also led to increased
environmental criticism the carbon
emissions produced by the energy needed
to
maintain these blockchains has forced
some in the nft market to rethink their
carbon footprint
what is a this fungible well it's a
mutually interchangeable
and in the case of this one here the one
snowden is talking about um it's
non-interchangeable
they paid five million bucks for it so
this is the new world that we have uh we
no longer trade
goods now and we don't even trade like
for services uh muscle services you know
like cutting the lawn
or or a barber barbering your hair
whatever hairdresser
you know now it's all this abstraction
we're moving into a world of abstraction
everywhere internet workers you know
scammers
we got all kinds of stuff out there
incredible
so you know if you're thinking about
living a long time get ready you know
you might be surprised that we're all
going down the drain very very fast okay
so don't make plans for the future okay
uh just in case
anyways uh who is this uh fellow ed
snowden
well i wrote an article on quora you can
find it there on
good oled corn uh ed snowden really i
didn't write it on him i
wrote it on his pal assange okay
julian assange's is probably
better known or just as well known as as
ed snowden
right and uh so this is his uh
lady uh i guess his his uh
wife and this is what they do these days
again
a lot of internet stuff they say oh my
husband's famous i think what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna take off my clothes
and get a lot of shots put them on the
internet you know and
of course uh you can have maybe book
writing and some other stuff
uh accompany this and they had a baby in
december okay i guess she flew to um
russia and they had their good night
over there
and on the right hand side you see mr
assange
another u.s intelligence asset
and that's uh i think 2016
2017 they were on the streets of um
of london they were walking the streets
of london they had two kids at the
embassy
that could have happened in the embassy
but certainly that's not them in the
embassy right there they're on the
streets and this
uh contrasts a little bit with this you
know
this is how assange was in 2012
he was cooped up in the um ecuadorian
embassy with all the bobbies around him
uh up there in london right and so uh
what a cheese you know
here's the bobby's they're trying to get
him out of there they said
you know uh that they also
eavesdropped in different ways inside
the embassy
and here's this guy you know there on
the lower right
uh close to the center now and he's
walking the streets of london
i mean how bad can the uh mi5s and mi6
be that they can't
they don't realize this guy's walking
the streets of london
yeah you gotta be quite quite uh
dummy to believe in that assange and
snowden are
anything but u.s intelligence assets in
fact
in the case of snowden he went to um
china
he was in hong kong and you know
when when i came to the cubans and to
the russians
not so much to the russian who went
through cuba but they accepted they
opened
you know they they rolled out the red
carpet for me you know
uh snowden goes to china you would think
the chinese would say hey what a chance
we got this guy snowden he
he left the united states uh
we can recruit him as an asset they gave
him three days
three days 72 hours to leave china
they didn't buy it and so the guy goes
out and he's going to go to
south america and he's going through
moscow
and it turns out he goes to moscow he's
going to go to south america or
some country down here and it turns out
the united states you know goes through
the motions
of notifying any country that receives
snowden that they would be in trouble
and so no one accepts snowden you know
gives them
asylum and he ends up staying in russia
very good very well planned and did
russia
come out well no russia i'm sure mr
poutine knows that
snowden is a u.s spy but he's not there
to spy on
russia he's there to spy on the american
public
that's his that's his job is there he's
there to
misinform disinform the american public
he's there to lead them by the nose
okay and uh yeah i mean this is the
world we live in today
how long such a thing can last i cannot
imagine
when these are the things that
governments have to do
so this is in the background as well
right uh
so let's uh get on with some of the
issues related to extinction
and here you have a couple
questions that people asked okay so
let's go over
some of those uh someone says united usd
collapsing doesn't mean
bitcoin collapse at the same time let in
hemp can be money too
you're going to have to have a hard time
getting rid of all the money
uh these people don't understand they're
so so
into uh money into investment
and trade and all that stuff you can't
get their minds off of that
you know they don't think that bitcoin
is money
yeah all all things are money anything
you can
exchange whether you barter or uh
or uh or just uh use as currency
all of it is money okay so uh
you know to say that bitcoin is not
going to fall
when the dollars in the world and the
euros in the world are no longer
you know have no value it's just
incredible it just shows how brainwashed
people really are
you can't get them out of that mode i
can't even talk to a lot of these people
because they just close their ears now
all they can understand is business and
you know and investment and all that
kind of stuff
yeah uh bitcoin is money and if there
are no dollars
out there then you can't have a world of
just bitcoin
okay because at some point you're going
to have to trade them
for for example dollars or euros or gold
or something else
that has value that you can exchange out
there for
among other things food you know and so
to say that you get a lot of bitcoins
in in your pocket which is just this
abstraction that's floating out there
uh without any other money on the on the
planet
i don't think so but yeah this is what
these people believe you can't even
talk to them uh another fellow
says what is it the pandemic
and lockdowns are to match the death of
fractional reserve banking
the lockdowns are there to control
spending in the economy and stabilize
feed
price prices until they can get us all
on board with another [ __ ] criminal
scheme
real money cannot die it's called barter
their house of cards is coming down all
these people think of this uh
conspiracy you know that the rich
somehow are compelling everybody to go
into this
uh chicken coop you know the poor people
just putting them there and control them
you know when the uh [ __ ] hits the fan
and the world economy finally collapses
totally collapse it disintegrates so
that nobody
accepts money anymore and there is no
more money
well the rich have lost all their power
what are they gonna
uh do to keep their um their gangs
you know the people who their their
enforcers what are they gonna pay him
with uh money
you know uh again uh and and
you know the people who are the
enforcers
they have no reason have any loyalty to
the boss anymore
and probably the first guy to go will be
the rich guy
he's probably old he's relying all these
young guys to protect them and it turns
out they say hey we don't need you old
man
so they might even eat them pro you know
you know just put them on the uh
barbecue yeah uh
no uh when when money collapses there
will be no loyalty
we're we're back to the stone age where
uh in in the stone age we had no money
there was no such thing as trade
and we lived without trade for 90
of our existence human existence so
another uh this notion that
that you know uh the world collapses but
you're still going to do your thing out
there
with money or trade or barter no no any
in the asphalt jungle without money no
one trusts anybody
and there is no trade because the only
thing of value
is food and city folk don't seem to
understand that
or they never thought about this you
know at all
and one fella says in here along that
same line he says
uh food is money
uh no food is not money
food is money today under our
or you know our system today so anything
is money today
even prostitution is money and give the
girl for some money or whatever
you know everything is money today but
the day that
money collapses that money is no more
that trade is no more
whatever food you have you will not
give away if anything you'll go out
there and steal whatever someone else
has
but you will not give the little food
that you have away
to think that you're going to be
bartering bananas for apples
just shows the mentality of some people
that's how it shows it shows how
ignorant these people
are and these are city folk that think
they're smart you know
yeah incredible another foul says what
money ending makes just as much sense as
everyone forgetting to eat
you need to explain marketing with
rational science to explain your
hypothesis
properly okay uh
well people don't understand that when
money disappears completely
it's the end of food and
it's so hard to get that across the
people today because we take food for
granted
and yet last year you know i don't know
if
if your memory reaches that far what was
it april or may
they started um rationing a lot of stuff
among them
toilet paper and i don't know if people
remember that at all but you could go
you you could go almost anywhere here in
germany you know uh
they rationed food items and people
could not take uh more than one or two
packets of
different items from the shelves
suddenly overnight
here in uh first world country you know
and you say
how can this happen here in europe
you know are we back to the days of the
weimar republic where you know every you
know
they were going with their cartwheels
full of money to buy
a loaf of bread and
scarcity and all that stuff uh soup
kitchens
are we going back to that and yeah we
could go overnight just like
it happened last year people
don't realize how quickly things can
deteriorate
suddenly you know you go to the
supermarket and they don't allow you to
take more than one item
two items or whatever they put some
rationing
system in place or worse they might say
we can't sell you this or we don't have
any of this because we didn't receive
any deliveries
a lot of stuff can happen and that can
happen overnight
so you know when people don't understand
that it's just unbelievable for me it's
just
incredible and before that you need to
explain the mechanism of how
past extinctions uh especially mass
extinctions happened
extinction 101. see uh uh people
want to talk about man everybody's an
expert on man you know we all
know men like the palm of our hands
and what do they say they say they
always argue the same thing
they know how man is not going to die
it's not going to die man's not going to
disappear the way you say bill
okay and so what do you propose instead
and you'll never see or hear a proposal
you'll never hear them say this is how
man
will disappear and uh
and so you say well is it guaranteed
is your mechanism the one that you're
proposing for man's extinction assuming
you believe that man's to become extinct
right that's the first question but
assuming you do
believe that man's going to become
extinct in the future
by what mechanism that man cannot
elude that's the question because if men
can elude it you don't have a foolproof
system
means that you know i i can have an
antidote to your
argument because i can you know i can
come up and say ah but this
and he said well yeah we know that it's
not foolproof
well then you don't have a mechanism see
the food mechanism
is a full proof mechanism
if food disappears
man disappears that part hopefully is
is undebatable and you'd be surprised
people say no no
even if food disappears man will be
they'll say this okay so you got a lot
of people who haven't
gotten past that point you know and uh
so yeah if food disappears i think
humans will disappear that's a foolproof
mechanism now whether you believe
food will disappear that's a separate
issue but
if food disappears if you we make that
assumption
well hopefully uh you conclude that man
will
necessarily invariably disappear
and sometimes very hard for people to
even understand that much
it's incredible okay um so yeah you got
to do this you got to do extinction
101 before you do extinction 102. what
is extinction 101
well it's a mass extinction you have to
explain how the animals in the past died
okay how they disappeared and you know
today we have catastrophic
theories from the so-called paleontology
establishment
not one in the last 200 years has been
able to explain
background extinction or the background
extinctions or mass extinctions neither
one we don't have a foolproof mechanism
for
extinctions and not one of them suspects
that man will become extinct
so obviously they don't understand
anything about extinction
and that's the job of a paleontologist
he's a medical examiner he's a detective
a uh
a guy who studies death that's what uh
paleontology does that's his job
he's got to tell us how species in the
past died
that's his number one job all the other
stuff that you know
scraping bones from from the rock and
assembling them giving a fancy name and
putting them in a
museum that's not paleontology that's uh
stamp collecting okay paleontology is
one thing and one thing only and that's
explaining how the animals in the past
died
that's what we have to explain and if
you can't explain that you're not a
paleontologist
just that simple and then yeah once you
explain
past extinctions you can move on to men
and say well how will men
become extinct and here are the problems
you know
some people don't even recognize that
humans are animals
they think we're not you know we poop we
eat we sleep
we have sex you know some of us
and uh and they still say well yeah but
we're not animals
but that's what all animals do out there
how are we different than animals
and we are categorized under mammals
okay
because we have our babies women do
right uh
through their uh uterus we don't lay
eggs
not outside at least you know we lay
them inside
and uh and so people don't recognize
that we're animal we belong to the
animal kingdom we don't
belong to the plant kingdom and we don't
belong to the
rocks and mineral kingdom we belong to
the animal kingdom and within that we
belong to the mammals
and and if mammals uh in the past have
died
relatively recent past and dinosaurs
have died and
and archosaurs have died and mammal-like
reptiles and amphibians they've died in
the past
these were all animals right different
kinds of animals well
since we're animals we're probably going
to die as well disappear as well we're
going to become extinct
and so to say that oh no where do you
we're the only exception in the animal
kingdom we don't become extinct
well you know again a lot of
brainwashing there a lot of uh
wishful thinking and then yeah uh
extinction can happen if food disappears
if if that's a big if right if food
disappears
man will die if we have nothing to eat
how long can
you live without eating i mean you can
live without breathing
for a few seconds maybe minutes you can
live without
um water maybe a few days
right but without food you know
you you can't live for a long time okay
certainly not i don't think you can live
over two months
except an indian guy who says he's been
without eating for
45 years
and i always say with my son yeah yeah
oh man i know how it feels
you know i haven't eaten since this
morning it's like i haven't eaten in 45
years too
[Laughter]
anyways uh food chain collapse it's a
selective
mechanism some animals die and some
animals don't so now we have a clue
there that maybe that created the
extinction of the dinosaurs
and left the mammals alive and they left
a bunch of fish in the uh seas alive
whereas the reptiles the you know
mosasaurs and so on
uh they vanished and in the air you know
the pterodactyls they were flying around
they disappeared the flying reptiles and
what remained worth birds
so uh it's it's a selective mechanism
the food chain okay and uh
that little square little rectangle
there that i
uh underline there food disappears if
money disappears
lots of people don't understand that and
people say well
bill tell us how money is going to
disappear
well we can't get that far because we're
stuck on that other one
a lot of people still don't believe that
if money disappears
food disappears they're still they're
still wondering about that one
forget about you know money disappearing
right now
they can't understand that if food if
money disappears food will disappear
and so we got to get to that step first
okay so
yeah i don't i don't think it's worth
even
talking about how money will disappear
yet
because there's too many people who
don't believe that food disappears if
money disappears
and i showed the uh chain of um
uh food the other day the fact that all
these
these connections uh only run because of
money
and if you cut those chains of money
currency anything
bitcoin uh if you cut that chain
you know the system doesn't run anymore
no one produces food no one distributes
food
the supermarkets don't sell food
and you can have all the money you want
in the bank it's not going to help you
at all because there won't be any food
because no one will be producing it
why because money has disappeared and
they have no pecuniary
incentive to to produce or distribute
food
so that is the bottom line okay
here's another issue said how the food
chain of
dinosaurs disappeared what was the cause
behind the disappearance of
food uh of dinosaurs okay
that's an important question so let's
address that i've addressed it in the
past i'll just go quickly through it
okay here it is uh here you can see the
types of plants
that uh were around in the devonian all
the way to
cenozoic okay and what you see there
is that the ferns dominated early on
then they were
overtaken by the gymnosperms and finally
by the
angiosperms which is what rules the
planet today
so the issue is that when a
big family order of plants disappears
the animals that forge the relationship
with those plants
and carved niches in different types of
plants
of those days when those plants
disappear the animal
will disappear as well it's just that
simple it's a relatively gradual process
which then comes to
you know uh an abrupt stop
right at the end but yeah that's that is
the mechanism
and uh here's a another
graph that i'd like to show okay it's
known as the cretaceous
terrestrial revolution and you can see
here here's the uh
blueprint or the uh here's the pattern
that shows
how dinosaurs disappeared okay here it
is okay you can see the red there
those are the angiosperms and we're
talking about number of species not
quantities but you can imagine that uh
if there were more number more
species of angiosperms there were also
more quantities of it in covering the
planet
and taking over the land they were
displacing
the cycads the ferns as well there was a
fern spike
towards the end but they were replacing
the cycads the conifers the ginkgos
okay there's only one brand of one uh
strand of ginkgo today okay and so you
can see
what happened from about the middle
maybe a little fur
earlier uh of the cretaceous the
angestar
sperm started muscling in on all
the other plants and they eventually
covered the land today most of our
planet
only has angiosperms okay we have
we have conifers you know but uh you
know no mammal
really eats conifers and we don't eat
ferns
okay maybe there's one or two exceptions
out there you gotta look through it you
know someone who says oh
this animal eats this part of the fern
over here like
something special and mammals don't eat
ferns mammals don't eat conifers
so guess what happens when angiosperms
disappear and it turns out we don't need
all angiosperms you know like
humans we don't eat grass and some of
the grasses out there or weeds you know
we don't eat a lot of those
things and those are angiosperms they're
flowering plants
we don't eat a lot of those we eat
special types of
angiosperms you know and yeah um
so when those plants disappear we
disappear and that's essentially what
happened to the animals in the past
the uh their food sources uh they were
these big jungles originally big forests
and they became shrinking islands what i
call
my shrinking island process where uh
the food sources become smaller and
smaller and smaller
and eventually the animals can't find
enough to eat
and they begin to uh have problems
and their numbers begin begin to
decrease
okay so it has to do with plants plants
disappearing
and this is the mechanism it's called i
call it the overturning
of the population pyramid of plants
and you'll see two graphs here or two to
um
images here one has to do with the
overturning of the
animal kingdom the other one with the
plant kingdom okay here it is
okay the one on the top is the animal
kingdom and you can see what happens
uh we have uh ten to one ratio between
traffic levels
uh there's about ten times as much
uh primary production as there are
herbivores
there's about ten times as many
herbivores as there are predators
okay what happens towards the end is
that overturns
why because as you can see uh what
happens is what disappears there
is the greenery the primary production
and what happens to the greenery to the
primary production is that
their population pyramid overturns okay
and you have with that a loss of genetic
diversity
you know you see a lot of plants today i
mentioned this
in the past where you find peaches you
know i i grow
uh different kinds of uh plants and
fruits out there
you got a little uh plot of land
and i do just for for investigation for
research and
you know i have this beautiful peach
tree
and last year i had five five
siamese twins among the peaches
you know they come out like two you know
like
uh blended by the belly
so you have a double peach come out and
i had
five of those on my tree and it turns
out when you look at the history of
peaches
uh a few thousand years ago they were
like little berries
and because of human um
you know artificial selection we made
them grow over time
you know we selected and planted what we
really wanted
and the peaches grew over time today we
have these
they're not berries anymore they look
more like apples apple size pear size
but the peaches have lost their genetic
diversity
and so now you can see why we're having
siamese twins come out of the trees
and it's not only the peaches i mean if
you look on the internet
just look up images for
siamese fruits and veggies
and you'll find out which ones are at
the end of the line because
you know a lot of them are coming out as
siamese twins
meaning from my theory that they lost
their genetic diversity
and if you add to that the fact that we
are a lot of them are coming out without
seed
we have seedless grapes seedless
watermelons or
or you know the seeds are becoming
smaller
and we have seedless limes and so on
a lot of these trees are grown
vegetatively you know
they go out there and they pull out a
little branch and they
stick it in the ground and grow another
tree and so it's all cloning
and that's not good uh for humanity
because
you know we don't have uh the plants
growing
normally the way they should and all
we're doing is extending their
you know life expectancy a lot of these
plants should have gone
you know sour a long time ago and we're
keeping them alive by replanting them
over and over
okay anyways um here's another
issue fellow raises i guess you must
hate women
he says lack of patriarchy not cities is
the common factor bill
patriarchal uh uh patriarchal
societies still have kids uh-huh
he thinks it's an issue of uh this uh
thing that we had in the past where men
dominated
and now women are coming up to speed and
they're more or less
you know uh becoming our equals
[Laughter]
and so you know i i have a couple of
arguments one is that bacteria growing
on a piece of uh
bread uh they're you know they're not
organized particularly
and that's why you have to do extinction
101
before you do extinction 102. you got to
look at why
animals and why plants disappeared in
the past
and also why you know they
went through this population curve okay
and so no it's a it's guaranteed all
species will eventually get to their uh
curve their s curve and the s curve as i
explained in a couple videos ago
ends up in extinction always it's not an
s curve like you know it stops there
they should continue with the s curve
and shows that it goes all the way to
zero
and ten families better go but
patriarchal nuclear within a sea of
bachelors
is not equal to reproduction today we
have a world of bachelors and more and
more people are not getting married
there are no long-term relationships
and so when you have whatever
group is still out there that still has
you know follows the
traditions me among them you know where
you get married you have kids
and so on and you live happily ever
after
that's going away very fast and today we
have a world of
bachelors essentially uh if there is
reproduction you know uh it's very
little
per couple and then a divorce they each
get new partners then they most of them
don't want to have kids and so on and so
forth
that's why we're not having uh children
but we're not having children
in in that scenario because we moved to
the cities
the key issue is that we went from the
country
to the cities and when you have high
density areas
you get into density dependent birth
rates
and so you got to look at these terms
and find out what they mean and
why it's deterministic
not free will women don't have the free
will to have babies
people say you're crazy bill uh my wife
can have a baby whatever she wants
well why doesn't she
why doesn't she have a baby with you i
mean maybe with her neighbor but
no we're not having babies collectively
that's the issue not
you can't go and say well my wife can
have a baby whenever she wants well yeah
maybe she can
but she doesn't when you take many
families many couples together
most of them will not have babies okay
that's the issue and if they do have
babies they won't have many they won't
have
10 kids like we used to have in the 19th
century
half of them died but it didn't matter
you still had five
today it's not even close okay so
no it's density dependent birth rate and
here you uh
you see a little image of that i showed
it in the past but let me show it one
more time
so you know what i'm talking about here
it is okay
there you have a couple fruits and this
has nothing to do with patriarchy
okay uh you know uh what you have there
is uh i call it the water gets you drunk
uh
theory people say well water with uh
whiskey gets you drunk water with beer
gets you drunk water with uh
wine gets you drunk so water is the
common factor right
well that's more or less what this uh
fellow the
air and his reasoning no it's density
dependent birth rates and there you see
it uh
when the bacteria or the fungus or
whatever you know attacks a uh
a fruit or veggie or whatever you know
they grow
at first exponentially you know if we
could count each one of
each each unit in there each individual
you would see that it's growing
exponentially but then after a while you
know they've eaten the fruit now they've
got this density dependence
they can't continue expanding
exponentially and that's when the curve
turns
okay so it's got nothing to do with uh
patriarchy yeah maybe they change their
habits their culture
that could be but why did they change
their culture because of density
dependence okay
uh okay another question here another
comment lots of comments on this that's
why i'm covering that because
there are lots of issues there could the
lack of biodiversity in humans be due to
a rather recent bottleneck in population
well again all these are theories okay
keep that in mind all these are theories
you can believe whichever theory you
want
you just gotta look at different
theories and then make up your own mind
if people are interested in the subject
they'll do research and
they'll find theories out there and some
you accept some you reject
depending on you know your your
upbringing your training
whatever you know uh many mammals that
have been around for a while and have
inbred to exhaustion have lost their
genetic diversity
so it's not that there was a recent
bottleneck in human population or
anything like that it's that
we're not the only animal that is
approaching density dependent uh
mode okay where there's other animal you
look at the alliance
about 50 years ago there were 150 000
lions in uh estimated right in uh
africa and today's only about 30 35
000 and dropping even with
conservationist
measures and again when population
drops so drastically you get also into
the issue of
uh genetic diversity you know you lose
genetic diversity because the few that
remain you know they're more or less
cousins and uh
and um part of maybe the same family the
same uh
great grandfathers the uh you know the
same uh
founders founders effect so um
yeah what happens is when you reduce the
population
you have less genetic diversity
especially if the
these animals have been around for a
long time and so
yeah lions have lost their genetic
diversity not to mention the cheetahs
cheetahs have no genetic diversity
probably the animal on earth that has
the least amount of genetic diversity or
one of the
you know one of the ones maybe the
komodo dragon is
around there as well okay and that's why
you got to do extinction 101 before 102
you got to
talk about animals before you talk about
this animal called
man okay another
comment issue says
says in such scenario i think north
korea would do really well
because they have plenty of autonomy
grow a lot of their own food
everything is state-owned everyone has
to do military conscription etc
north korea would actually last really
well
in a world where the global economy
plummets
people are so mistaken they're so
so mistaken you know i've been to cuba
and a couple times several times and um
you know like cuba like north korea
uh it's a capitalist country inside
cuba to a great extent what do i mean by
that
well uh there's a saying or there was a
saying in cuba when fidel with
castro was around and it's like you know
fidel castro will not
intervene in your daily activities if
you don't
intervene in politics you know
each one has his own realm and so yeah
they say well you know
cuba is all controlled everywhere which
it is
but the black market is booming it's
always been booming
all the ways to 1959 people you know
trade in secret and they uh
some not so secret secret you know it's
it's like
an open secret everybody knows that
everybody trades
and uh you know uh one time
i was driving um down the highway and
with a friend
cuban friend and the cops had stopped
a uh an individual who was coming from
the country to the city
in the city there's a lot of uh stuff
that's missing you know you don't have a
lot of
food especially meat there's almost no
meat in the cities
in havana old havana and so on
and in the country they live like kings
in comparison because you know
you grow your own chickens you grow your
own
pigs whatever and you can slaughter one
of them without anyone knowing and
you know having a feast and so what a
lot of the country folk do
to get some stuff from the city they
bring in their little
piglets and chickens and so on and they
bring them you know uh to the city
but then you have the cops and the cops
they patrol
the highway yeah highway patrol you know
broderick crawford
and uh and so um they stopped
this man and he had some pigs
in his uh in his truck
and a cop saw it there
and what the guy did was simply bribe
the cops
and everybody went on their merry way
you know the cops went one way and he's
get and this
fellow came the other way he just
brought his stuff to the city
so yeah there's a black market in cuba
uh you know i've seen people who work in
restaurants
take stuff home so
you know uh to say that uh cuba and
north korea and all these countries
that are communist uh to be different no
they they have to have commerce with the
west and there you see it
north korea has commerce with and
depends heavily on china
and north korea wants u.s economic
sanctions
lifted why if they don't do any commerce
why would they
be worried about u.s lifting sanctions
you know commercial sanctions well
because it's affecting them because they
need
goods in the country and the only way
they can get them is by trade
right now they're trading through china
which is like a little channel
you know a little tunnel through which
uh you know that's their umbilical cord
that keeps the country running
to a great extent because they don't
produce enough stuff because they're not
efficient
and uh and so uh you know
north korea will not survive if the rest
of the world
collapses neither will cuba because they
need other countries
in fact uh let me tell you a little
another anecdote when i was in cuba
i asked my handlers over there and i
said
uh you know cuba runs uh
quite inefficiently and they said
yeah we know oh you
you know yeah we know well
why don't you run it efficiently or more
efficiently than what
you have today and they said well in
order to do so we would have to give
incentives to people monetary incentives
i said okay and they said well
if we give monetary incentives to people
it'll destroy morale revolutionary
morale
and it would bring out the worst in man
and so that was their answer
so uh what they do is they rely on the
black
market and just don't get caught and
you'll do okay okay
nobody will do anything to you okay
um another comment here
lots of them like i said uh phil says
says there are many there are very many
marriages that the partnership has
separate bank accounts because i said
that that's the definition of marriage
one bank account if you have two bank
accounts you're not married
because what you're ready to run
uh in partner we trust i guess not right
especially in these this day and age
especially in the cities
uh no one trusts anyone especially their
partner they've heard so many stories so
they don't even get married
and a lot of women don't want to get
pregnant or have children because
of all the little stories that they hear
out there all these tales
so yeah uh this fella who says
many marriages that the partnership has
separate bank accounts well they don't
meet the definition
so they're not married that's the answer
to that okay
very simple yeah yeah you got to beat
the definition definition
is that you need to have one bank
account and not
not two okay another file
raises a little more important issue he
says the following
he says once more bill is in conflict
with his own beliefs
uh which he is calling um theories he
claims to make no predictions
but he is claiming again and again we
are the last generation on earth yes i
do claim that
and this claim is a prediction
uh no it's not a prediction see when
when you do a prediction
you got to set a date and time see i can
make a prediction right now
and say there will be an eclipse
guaranteed and you say
i bet you a million dollars that there
won't be an eclipse
and as long as we don't put a date
you know we you won't win the bet
okay i gotta put a date and time i gotta
say there's gonna be an eclipse tomorrow
at two o'clock
then you have something to verify you
know but otherwise if i say there won't
be any clips or there will be an eclipse
and i don't put a date and time
you know when it's going to happen well
is that a prediction
so we got to separate uh the issue here
the issue is that
i'm not making any prediction it has
nothing at
all to do with prediction you're
focusing on the wrong aspect
the as the correct context here
is that we're talking about explanation
of a mechanism how
an extinction happens especially a mass
extinction in the case of man
how does a mass extinction happen and
what we're doing is
extrapolating what happened to all the
animal
other animals in the past that became
extinct
to the future to us to us humans and
we're saying
we cannot avoid that same mechanism
if food disappears humans will
die no matter what invariably
and so the issue here is not that it's a
prediction in the sense that
we're going to put a date and time to
say oh on the 1st of may of
i don't know the year 2 2026 we're all
going to die or the last man is gonna
die
no no that's uh that's not what we're
saying we're saying that
we cannot avoid the mechanism that
killed the animals in the past
in a mass extinction or in mass
extinctions
we cannot avoid that same mechanism
therefore we will
die okay because the
mechanism is unavoidable that's why it's
not a prediction
in the traditional sense of saying give
me a date and time
it's got nothing to do with that it's
got to do with an unavoidable
mechanism and i'm not sure if i got true
to you
that's what it is and people don't
understand that the context is important
here to understand what the word
prediction means we're not making any
prediction we're explaining a mechanism
uh saying that we cannot avoid what
happened to the other animals
okay and uh yeah
you know the animals in the past type
because food disappeared
and we cannot we cannot avoid becoming
extinct
if if food disappears and what we're
saying is food will disappear because
that
is the mechanism mother nature uses to
get rid of species
even if they're the apex predators like
we are
so yeah we cannot avoid extinction
and we will obviously you know
become extinct i say quite soon whatever
soon means to
you you have to make up your own um
time frame depending on your education
on your
research on your upbringing but yeah we
were gonna die
and here you can see the what's happened
uh for ninety percent maybe or more
of uh human lifetime uh we were hunter
gatherers we just killed an animal and
lived another day that was it
and then uh anyway the numbers are not
important here but
they're just the the magnitudes are
important the fact that you can see
what's happening to the numbers here
about 10 000 years ago we went into
farming
and then 300 years ago or so we went
into manufacturing that was the mode of
production
primary mode of production we also had
different types of families in this
in these uh eras we had the in the
hunter gathering we had group sex
farming we had uh patriarchal uh
societies manufacturing was mom and pop
you know the
nuclear family and today in the service
economy we have the bachelor
okay we're moving into the bachelor mode
and uh yeah we we went
in fact there's two categories there as
you can see i've updated that graph
we used to have labor intensive services
like you know things that you did with
your hands
and today we have essentially
self-service
in other words uh internet uh jobs uh
everybody
is an entrepreneur all on his own okay
and so yeah and uh i say that um
that is essentially unemployment that's
what that's what that
kind of work is it's unemployment
because we're not producing anything
anymore
and it's the goods that make up the
wealth
of the planet and when god looks from up
there
mother nature the devil oh the devil's
down here i think and they look at our
planet they only see what's
what's real what's there the objects the
things we made
they don't see the promises you know
insurance
banking they don't see any of that
bitcoin they don't see any of that
that's that's all floating in the air
there's none of that
that's just faith that's all that is
faith so we have an economy today built
on faith
and when you know we in god we trust we
don't trust any more in god
well then faith is gone and so that's
the issue there
money is gonna be the killer um
and that's why i always keep saying you
gotta do extinction 101 before you do
extinction 102. okay
another issue that was raised not
necessarily related to extinction
could be depending on how you look at it
okay but this fella says
uh let me get this thing in here says it
is absolutely funny to know that
bill is an ex-communist who fought for
decades for
for a society which can finish the uh
rule of big money and the use of money
in general
well no that's that's not really what
communism was about
communism actually better known as the
dictatorship of the proletariat
which is what we have if anything on
earth today we don't have communism at
all
on earth today uh the so-called
communist countries they're in the phase
known as dictatorship of the proletariat
okay where the workers take over the
government supposedly
okay at least ideally and they run the
country
in opposition to what happened before
which was
the rich people run the country and
that's not true
there's still rich people in cuba and in
north korea and so on that run the
country that's the reality of it okay
some people have
benefits and i noticed this when i was
in cuba okay
you have all these rich people running
the country and
or people who have access to uh things
like you know fidel castro when i was
down there he had access to
a couple of mansions he lived well he
had
several cars he had this group that
protected him and went with him
everywhere
so he's got this little empire where he
runs the country he's the
big macho guy there you know and he eats
well he
he ate meat whenever he wanted uh the
average cuban does not okay
and that is important to understand you
know let me tell you why because uh let
me get this out of here
for a second um
think about it you know i was a
communist and uh
i was an atheist so what do atheists
believe in well atheists
uh believe that your soul
does not exist that there is no such
thing as a soul
and so when you die there is no soul
that goes to heaven and lives forever
okay and so if your soul is not there
because there's no such thing as soul or
conscience or mind that
leaves the body and goes to heaven and
lives forever
then this is the only life you get to
live and when you die that's it
you know your atoms get absorbed by the
land and then become part of plants and
some animal eats it and now they've got
the atoms
that belong to you that's more or less
we probably have dinosaur atoms in our
bodies today
okay dinosaur die became part of the
land the plant grows has some of those
atoms and we eat the plant we have
now a little bit of dinosaur in us uh
one atom that belonged to
some animal in the past so there's only
one life we get to live
and so now this is the issue one of the
issues that triggered in me you know
um here you have fidel and all these
communists and they say
oh we have to make the revolution okay
for what
well we have to make the revolution so
that
our children our great grandchildren all
these people will finally be able to
live
in a society in the egalitarian society
well uh i live today
i don't even know if i'll get to see my
great-grandchildren
and so this is the only life i get i'm
not going to go to heaven
because i'm an atheist right and so this
is the only life i get
to live and you're saying bill you've
got to sacrifice yourself
for the revolution
i see i have to sacrifice myself for the
revolution
fidel lives in a mansion and i got to do
it
because temporarily yeah someone's got
to be the boss there's got to be
a dictatorship of the proletarians up
there you know
few people who take decisions for the
rest of the country
and you know we have to respect that
because that's the way it is until
everybody is equal on planet earth which
will be
three or four generations down the road
if we're lucky right
something's wrong with that because it
means i'm sacrificing my life you're
saying
bill you got to be a slave for the rest
of your life and build a pyramid for the
pharaoh
so that eventually we can all
be kings that's essentially what the
message
is of communism of the dictatorship of
the proletariat
right now we have dictatorship i don't
know about communism which is
this egalitarian society where all like
lincoln said you know all men are
created equal
uh he was a communist obviously uh no mr
lincoln
and uh secretary of war edwin stanton
showed him
that he was wrong had him murdered so uh
yeah no
communism has no future and
uh because there is no such thing as
communism except as an ideal
right now we have the best we have is
dictatorship of the proletariat
and within those dictatorship of the
proletariats
the powers that be they look the other
way and let you do your black market
just
don't get caught okay because it's
illegal to do black marketing which is
what everybody does
it has to do if they want to survive one
more day and
have a more or less decent life so
that's the way it really works
okay and this other fellow says
something along the same lines says
imagine how
intel felt when they realized you
plagiarized their pentium chip
and dropped it off in cuba the good news
the fbi caught your ass
[Laughter]
uh well this poor fella he doesn't know
the story doesn't know the story at all
uh no uh the fbi did not catch my ass
okay not at all you gotta read the story
or
watch the movie or whatever no the fbi
worked with me they worked with me
for a couple years and the issue was
that they went
in there and they asked me to take
material out of intel corporation
specifically run cart known as the 6295
it's a recipe a a
step-by-step uh
instructions on how to build a specific
device
and uh you know it's a little card uh
elongated card and they asked me to pull
that out of
intel and give it to them which i did
and uh because they needed to give it to
the cubans to make them believe
that everything was normal their counter
espionage
project or or their what they were doing
their work
overruled the giving of intel technology
and all they had to make sure is that
the technology was not critical
and what i did not only did i film them
and i showed that the other day where uh
in fact i think i have that here
uh here's the the oven cam
okay which i put in my oven okay
and there you see uh this agent
fbi agent he's paying me okay
and uh there's the oven cam you'll see
in a second there okay that's how i put
it in my
oven and whenever he would come in and
pay me well
he was filmed he was on candid camera
[Laughter]
and but that's not the only thing i did
see when i gave him the 6295
right run card i gave him the card and
he looked at it and he said okay
this this is good i think we can use
this and we talked a little he went to
the bathroom
and what he didn't know is that i
switched run cards on him
i had two run cards and so i switched
the run cards on him and kept the one
with his fingerprints
and so they knew that eventually you
know
years later they knew about it when i
went to trial
and not only did i have them filmed i
had their fingerprints
i had a couple money orders which i
still have
in which uh i i also had their
fingerprints here
okay and all that you know was
documented
and i had a handwriting expert to show
that this was
a specific fbi agent and so i had them
buy the balls
that's why they gave me a lenient
service sentence
because the prosecutor was between the
sword and the wall
on the one hand they had intel who
really wanted to get
at me but the prosecutor wanted to get
me without getting the
fbi agents in prison that was the issue
and if they did get them in there you
know either we were all
absolved or we were all going to prison
and so this was the issue the other
issue was that you know
in argentina i had the cia come over
and uh they interviewed me etc
but before that happened i was arrested
first by the
argentine uh really the secret service
okay and i was kept in uh in a cell for
several days until they questioned me
and um one of the things they talked
about or they asked me about was iran
he said why did he ask you about iran
what does that have to do with
intel and amd and all that stuff well at
the time it still had nothing to do with
them
they the the reason they arrested me was
that
it turns out that uh there was a bombing
of the
uh israel embassy in argentina lots of
people were killed like 80 or 90.
and then they had the anja the mutual
association
of israelites also and that was bombed
as well and a lot of people died there
as well
and so the cia was in our and the fbi as
well they were in argentina working with
ec
there which is the argentine secret
service intelligence service
intelligence i'm not sure how much
intelligence they have
they were working together and they were
trying to get evidence
against iran
and here they see this guy walking with
a camera blind guy you know
walking with a camera walking into the
iranian embassy
and i was going in there for something
totally different i was not even aware
that uh the argentine intelligence was
working with the cia
uh in uh investigating iran i had no
idea
and so they kept their cameras
everything's for sure focused on the
iranian embassy
uh having a major avenue libertadores
and uh i go in there and they started
following me and then
they arrested me they arrested me and
they asked me a bunch of questions about
iran okay so it turns out that meanwhile
the fbi wanted to get me
wanted to talk to me but they didn't
want to talk to me in the united states
because
they had warned me listen to this this
is what the fbi does
they warned me that there was a
case uh being raised by intel
in california and that the prosecutors
were investigating and they were going
to bring a
case against me a criminal case against
me so they said don't come to the states
because
more than likely you're going to be
arrested we're warning you
and i said okay so where do you want to
talk to me here in argentina i said no
why don't we meet in mexico
okay so we made a date we made an
appointment to meet in mexico city
they went to mexico city and i came to
arizona to sky harbor in phoenix
so i went to the to the united states
directly i
i didn't go to mexico and that pissed
them off because you know
you came directly and i was in the
united states
and i said well you know this is going
to blow over
it's it's either going to no one's going
to do anything about it or
a lot of us are going to be in trouble
and everybody knew that
and so the prosecutor had no choice but
to bring the case against me because
intel was insisting
so they did bring me to court and
the uh prosecutor knew very well that
the fbi would be involved
as well because of all the evidence i
had against them
so they they were in deep trouble and so
that's why we had to reach a
negotiated agreement where we sat down
and you know exchanged ideas
and the big idea was that they would go
we're gonna go after my wife
and so that was the issue the issue was
that uh they said look we go after your
wife
and uh you know you you take your
chances there
and we take our chances with our people
here and so we decided to
uh plea bargain instead that's the way
law works
so now the fbi never caught me i turned
myself in in fact twice to the fbi
and uh and when i did three times three
times to the fbi i turned myself
in after running out there and when i
turned myself
in they still were in trouble so that we
had to reach an agreement there was
another way of doing this
okay let's get on with the subject
matter of today which is
a sphere do we know what a sphere is
yeah let's find out what a sphere is and
uh let me start with this fella
and his name is euclid we always go to
euclid why because he was
the guy who formalized all this stuff he
was a greek guy
a greek uh citizen he lived really in
alexandria that uh
egypt you know that's where he did his
uh work
but he did go to aristotle's um
school okay uh in athens
the lyceum and which
yeah again in athens and uh that's where
he got his
uh education then he went to alexandria
and he wrote this book
kind of condensed all the knowledge of
the greeks regarding geometry in those
days
and he came up with these definitions
which again they're not really his
because you'll see that in
aristotle's book on physics
he has that same exact definition that
which has no part for the point
you'll see it in if you look up i think
it's chapter six
of physics and you'll find that same
definition i don't remember the chapter
now
uh but i can look it up anyways um
that which has no part was around that
was a notion that the greeks had
meaning it has no dimensions it has no
size
no volume no no anything that's what a
point is that's how they defined it
and what is a line well a line is
breathless
length and again uh what is it
what is the line made of made of points
what were the points zero dimensional
nothing there no dimension no size no
anything
and so a straight line the fourth
definition there is a line which
lies evenly with the points on itself
a line is made of points it's regarded
to be
one-dimensional today uh he defined it
as a bunch of points
which again he was referring to
locations
so a line is a bunch of locations
meaning an itinerary
and there you have what a point is and
what a line is nothing
there's no such thing as a point or no
such thing as a line
as a geometric figure there is no figure
called line there is no figure called
point
because point is location and line is
itinerary
motion that's what it is okay that's how
it's defined
and that's how it's used you know uh
geometers physicists uh mathematical
physicists
they have no use for objects and that's
why the word object has
never been defined you won't find a
single
textbook of physics on planet earth in
any country
that begins with the definitions of what
an object is
okay why because they never use objects
and you would think that if you can't do
physics without object meaning you
cannot explain a mechanism
without an object then uh the first word
you need to
define is the word object because the
first principle of physics is that you
can't do physics
without an object just that simple
okay so uh where do we go from here well
um
here we have uh the line of mathematical
physics today
and it's a nitrogen there's a bunch of
locations they depict them with little
points will dots
but each one of those dots has two
dimensions because you can see it
there is no object that is
one-dimensional or zero-dimensional
let alone four-dimensional uh so
you know they they have to put a dot in
there to put something physical so that
you can relate to it
because what are they going to put the
word location in there are they going to
put the word
uh motion or displacement
or itinerary what are they going to put
in there
so that's what it is that's what the
line of uh
so-called geometry is today it's not a
geometric figure it's just an itinerary
okay okay and why is that important well
because here you have euclid's circle
which he again he defined in the same
way essentially okay
and he says in first uh three three
definitions involving the circle so
definition 15 a circle is a plain figure
no it
ain't not not to this day it ain't a
figure okay but contained by one line
remember it was a line a bunch of points
a bunch of locations
that all the straight lines falling upon
it from one point among those lines
within the figure
equal one another in other words the
center point okay so there you have it
that's
that's euclid's notion of a circle it's
just a bunch of
rays going from the center to a point
that makes up the line the curved line
that you know encapsulates what is known
as a circle
okay and no in fact uh
the geometers today the mathematical
physicists they will clarify that the
inside of the circumference what's
inside of it is not part of the circle
they say the it's the circumference
which is the circle
and if you include the center part it's
called a disk
so what is the word circle for then if
if
all we have is circumference and disk
and then
definition 16 and the point is called
the center of the circle there you see
it okay
and definition 17 a diameter of the
circle
is any straight line drawn through the
center and terminated in both directions
by the circumference of the circle
uh and such a straight line also bisects
the circle okay and you say bill why do
we need to know all this i thought we
were talking
we're going to talk about spheres well
uh
please uh have a little patience i'll
get there okay
give me a chance here so uh what is a
circle according to mathematical physics
today i mean is it any different than
this
it's slightly different okay it's the
same thing but it doesn't include
all these rays okay and here it is this
is what it is
okay it looks like this similar but
without the rays
from the center the circle today is just
an itinerary
a uh an orbit that's what it is it's an
orbit and you see two definitions there
both of them pulled out of the wikipedia
all points in a plane that are
at a given distance from a given point
the center
and what's the other notion the curve
traced out
by a point meaning a location right
that moves in a plane so that its
distance from a given point is constant
in other words it's the orbit of a
location that's what a circle
is and if it doesn't include the center
well i don't know
how it can be called the plane all we
have is really a little line
which is really not a line it's just an
itinerary
it's an orbit around the center and
that's what they call a circle
that's not a plane not a plane at all
and certainly not a figure okay because
an itinerary
is not a figure and again you say bill
why do we need to know all this to know
what a sphere
is well here goes okay from there we
move on to
um the semicircle okay
we need to know these notions to know
what a sphere is okay that's why i'm
putting all this up here
okay here's the semi-circle okay
according to euclid okay
what is it a semi-circle is the figure
the answer figure okay
contained by the diameter and the
circumference cut off by it
and the center of the semi-circle is the
same as that of the circle
so that's a semi-circle's half a half a
half
of euclid's circle which includes all
these rays okay
and again all these rays they do not
make
a plane a plane is a continuous surface
this guy is saying uh no it's a bunch of
arrays a bunch of arrows uh
lines whatever and each line is an
individual unit
and between any two lines there are
gazillions of lines
okay because they're not talking about
lines because they're talking about
itineraries and itineraries are made of
locations and between
any two locations you can fit gazillions
of locations
because it's a concept it's not a
physical object
okay you can't just be making the point
smaller and smaller and smaller that's
not what it is
okay what we're talking about is
locations that's why they say that
between
any two points you can fit gazillions of
points because they're not talking about
physical objects physical objects you
cannot fit gazillions of
points between two points because you
just got to find out what the
size of the point is and there is only a
given distance between any two points
you can fit only so many points in
between but when you turn the point into
locations well you can fit as many
locations as you want
and time also you can fit as many
seconds as you want between there are
gazillions
of a second in between there okay and
what is a um
uh what is a semi-circle according to
the
uh great the illustrious mathematical
physics of today
well here it is uh if i can put it up
there
what happened uh
something happened here
oh i see okay okay here it is
uh this is the semi-circle of
mathematics
again uh today and again you can see the
only thing that's missing are the rays
okay it says a semicircle is a
one-dimensional
locus of points that forms half of a
circle
and another definition says a
semi-circle is a two-dimensional
geometric shape
no it ain't but that forms half of a
circle
and then you see what wolfogram has in
two of its uh
sites so as a semicircle is a half
circle
formed by cutting a whole circle along a
diameter line
and another one a little shorter you
know concise
half a circle that's what it is okay
what is a circle well it's a bunch of
points what is a point it's a location
so we're talking about an itinerary
and that's what we have we have half an
itinerary
that's what that was what a semicircle
is okay so where does this
all lead to well it leads to this
what is euclid's sphere okay we're
talking about euclid's sphere here okay
well this is it okay uh actually not
that's not euclid's sphere
let's put euclid's here uh sphere here
that's not the one i want to show let me
show this one okay
remove this one out of there give me a
second here
okay so this is uh euclid's uh
uh sphere okay he's gonna take a
semi-circle and he's going to spin it
around
okay he says this and he says that
that's what a sphere
is he's talking about a solid here okay
and it turns out it's a it's like a
wheel that you turn
half a wheel that you turn around he
says that's a sphere
okay uh and the spokes you know moving
around
says when a semicircle with fixed
diameters carry around and restore it
again to the same
position from which it began to be moved
the figure
so comprehended is a sphere
okay what is a sphere according to
mathematical physics
well you you can guess almost they're
going to take that same semicircle and
do something with it okay and here it is
let me put it over here so you can
compare them side by side
series solid generated when a semicircle
is being rotated about its diameter
in three-dimensional space this is also
known as a perfect round
geometrical object no it's not an object
and it's not a figure a sphere
created by rotating a semi-circle with
radius
a around the y-axis does your answer
agree with the
what volume of a sphere yeah they're
talking about a volume they're talking
about something else they're not talking
about what a sphere is they're talking
about the volume
uh occupied by a sphere okay they're
talking about how much water the rubber
ducky displaces
that's what it's all about and i said
the region bounded by
x equals zero blah blah blah will be a
semi-circle which by
rotating about the x-axis
generates a semi-sphere whose volume is
blah blah blah blah blah
and then we have the stack exchange
again all these phds and they say what
is a
uh what is a sphere rotated half a
circle
in 3d some 3d shapes like the sphere
are constructed by rotating a planar
shape
around an axis no that's called a volume
that's not called a sphere
okay a sphere is a ball that's
that's what a sphere is okay and so yeah
all these people um
they're building all these things with
itineraries but but listen listen what
happens here
look at this let me show this again okay
see that that semi-circle is first built
with it as an itinerary okay those are
locations
so we're talking about a a a bunch of
locations okay we build the first half
circle
and then that is an itinerary
but then they're going to move the
itinerary around to build a sphere
so we have the motion or the orbit or
the
round about the trip
of a uh of a of an itinerary of a
trajectory of
of an orbit because you have half an
orbit and then that orbit orbits
that's what they have and this takes us
to one of the
uh funny things that they have out there
and you'll see why that's
related all to geometry in the end what
geometry is really about
and some of you have heard of the
tesseract which is regarded to be a four
dimensional
object and here it is here's the
analysis for that
and again you're talking about the
motion of motion that's what a tesseract
is
you also have the heifers hypersphere as
well but let's do the
the uh hyper
cube instead you have a cube
listen carefully here you have a cube
and the cube expands over time
think of it as a cubic balloon and you
inflate it
so the the cube grows over time becomes
bigger and bigger and bigger
okay so that with that you build that
photo a of a tesseract which is what you
see on the right hand
upper right hand corner there so you
have the beginning cube
and the ending cube and then the the
growth
is shown with these lines that connect
the
corners okay you understand that we have
the small
cube we have the ending cube okay the
beginning and the ending cube
and their corners are their vert
vertices are connected
by these lines which represent the
motion
of expansion okay that's in there you
see the
tesseract so when you look at a
tesseract that's what you're staring at
you're not staring at a cube
three-dimensional four-dimensional
cube what you're staring at is the
growth of a cube
the film of a growth of a
cube growing through time and uh
you're seeing that film in one
photograph
okay that's they condensed it and the
lines
are just there to represent that motion
that growth motion
those those lines that uh connect the
corners
okay okay that's the first part now we
take that
remember this is in motion okay it's
growing okay keep that in mind
we're having a box that's becoming
bigger right now they're gonna
turn that box but not as it's growing
okay what they really do is they wait
for the box to grow
and then they turn it give it give it a
different uh
location a different axis a different
tilt and then they do it again and then
they do it again and then they do it
again
so we have this box growing you take a
snapshot of that
now you rotate it a little bit now you
start again you have this box growing
you take a snapshot of it and you move
it a little bit and so on down the line
so you have the growth
of a cube over time
that film turns into a photograph now
you're going to take
that last photograph and you're going to
make a movie
of those using those pictures those
frames okay
and so we have the motion of motion
that's what a tesseract is
so let's look at this thing in motion so
that you can see what you're staring at
whenever you're looking at a tesseract
which is the same thing that they're
doing with the
semi semi
circle rotating it around and saying
that's a sphere
well this is the same thing they're
doing with the tesseract and here it is
okay
you've seen the test right here so what
you're staring at there
is the growth of the
uh in the box on the inside okay
and this is ridiculous because that's
not what it is what you see is the box
is really growing and the lines that
unite the corners
represent that growth and then they move
the whole thing around
so we have the motion of motion we have
a
a movie within a movie with within the
frame
of a movie that's what you're staring at
and then you're looking at the movie of
each one of these frames
so yeah the motion within one frame is
very scary stuff
and that's what they do exactly with the
hemisphere
i'm sorry with the semi-ah circle they
first build this
itinerary which is a curve and then they
move the curve
that itinerary around they say that's a
sphere
we're not even talking about a figure
okay but that's
that's geometry for you in a nutshell
okay so here are my conclusions
okay so that you can take this to
the bank okay okay so
let's uh summarize here point is equal
to a location that's what point
is in both euclid and today mathematical
physics what is a line
motion it's an itinerary okay it's a
bunch of locations
what is a circle it's the orbit of a
location
it's an orbit that's what it is it's not
a figure it's an
orbit it's something moving what is it
that's moving a location
the location is orbiting what's in that
location
a location no specified object what is a
semi-circle
well that's half a circle so it's half
an orbit
and the orbit itself is uh is
you know uh just stopped
it it start it has a starting point an
ending point but it doesn't go all
around just stops halfway
okay so that's an that's what a
semi-circle is
what is a sphere well they take that
orbit and they orbit it around they
twirl it around they say we're we're
twirling the orbit
half an orbit okay they could have
twirled the whole circle around but they
said no we're going to drill
half a circle we're going to twirl the
semicircle around which is what
a uh a semi itinerary that's what it is
and then what's uh the caesarek well the
same thing but
in cubic mode they say look the uh
tesseract is just the expansion of a box
okay and they're gonna freeze
the beginning and ending frame connect
them with lines which represent the
time the distance traveled
okay by the expanding cube and then
they're going to take that
make a single frame of the film with
that
and then we're going to make a movie
with that and twirl that around as well
same thing for for the sphere as for the
tesseract that's geometry condensed in a
nutshell for you
okay and uh today i'll have to skip the
questions i've gone over my
limit today i've got something to do and
what i'll do is i'll cover those
questions that people made i have quite
a few of those
i'll cover them on wednesday so we'll
see